اعود معك للقضيه الرئيسيه وهي ما روج له
بانواع اقامه علاقات مع بعض الدول العربيه
هو لمواجهه اقامه تحالف ضد ايران في مقال
لك تعتبر انه ما كان يتعين على الولايات
المتحده للقيام به فيما يتعلق بصنع السلام
الحقيقي في الخليج والشرق الاوسط ناجحت
فيه الصين واسمح لي ان اقتبس من مقالك ان
ما انجزه الصينيون كان خطوه تخفيض حقيقي
للتوتر من اجل ارساء السلام كيف تقيم هذا
النجاح الصيني وهل تتوقع المزيد منه
كان خطوه حقيقيه تجاهها تقليل التوترات
ولا شك بان الخصومه والتوترات بين
ايران او المملكه العربيه السعوديه ربما
كانت
المشكله الاساسيه
في منطقه الخليج العربي والمرتبطه بالنزاع
المسلح
سواء بشكل غير مباشر خاصه في حرب اليمن
القوه الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه منخرطه فيه والحوتين
بجانب الاخر مدعومون من ايران وكذلك اشكال
مباشره مثل اطلاق الصواريخ والمسارات ضد
مشاه نفط السعوديه في عام 2019
واغلب المراقبين استنتجوا بان ايران
مسؤوله عن ذلك فاذا ما
اذا كان هنالك تحت العلاقاتي بين هاتين
القوه الاساسيتين في جانبي الخليج العربي
فلا شك بان هذه خطوه تجاهك المنطقه اكثر
السلامه واستقرارا اما فيما يخص ما تفعله
الصينيون لاحقا متابعه بعد هذه الخطوه في
خلال ايام القليله الماضيه او دون يشير
الى ان الصيناء استضافات اجتماع الوزراء
خارجيه ايران والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
وناقشها خلال عام التحسين التعاون الواقعي
لاستعاده الخدمات الخطوط الجويه بين
البلدين وكذلك تعزيز خدماتي اشارات الدخول
المسافرين لكي يتحركوا من الدوله الى اخرى
واعتقد بان الصين ستستمر بدعم تطبيق
هذه المتابعه على استعاده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه وكما اود ان اضيف بيانات
اطراف الثالثه مفيده كانت مشاركه مثل
العمانيون
وبدا بانهم كانوا واسطنطا في دين جدا ثم
يخص التقدم الاخير لنهائي الحرب في اليمن
هل
الصين تتقدم في المنطقه على حساب الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه او بسبب تراجع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ام كيف سيكون الحال
بوجود الصين وامريكا في المنطقه
لان لديها علاقات مع الجميع في المنطقات
تماما كما لديها مع كافه المناطق العالم
ولا تحاول ان تقسم العالم الى اصدقاء
واعداء ونتحدث فقط عن الاصدقاء
تتجاهل ولا دعوه كان هذا هو
شاهدناه لتحقيق العلاقه تحسينها بين ايران
والسعوديه الولايات المتحده كانت تفعل نفس
الشيء اذا ما اتبعت سياسه مشابهه لعدم
تقسيم العالم الى اصدقاء واعداء والتحدث
مع الجميع ولكن سياسه امريكا كانت غير ذلك
هنا في الشرق الاوسط لا يوجد اي حوار او
حديث ما عدا على مسارات ضيقه مثلا مع
ايران ولا تجد اي محادثات مع النظام
السوري في دمشق
وبالتالي فان الولايات المتحده لم تضع
اساسي في موقف لتحقيق مثل هذه الانجازات
لو وسعت مقاربتها الدبلوماسيه تكون مشابهه
الصين وحتى مقاربه روسيا للشرق الاوسط
لانها تتحدث مع الجميع من اسرائيل الى
ايران فالولايات المتحده كان يمكن ان تكون
مفيده جدا للاستقرار الشرق الاوسط الى ان
موقفها يمنع ذلك حاليا